قال الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني
العميد نبيل عبد الله في مقابله مع
الجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع تسللت الى
منازل ضباط بالقوات المسلحه واحتجزت عددا
من الاسر
كل اسف انما عندنا تم اعتراض عدد كبير
الى مقرات عملهم تم اعتراضهم في الطريق
وثم التحفظ عليهم واعتقالهم وهذا امر
جرى منذ اليوم الاول
الاسوء من ذلك استغلوا وجود جميع الضباط
في مواقعهم وهم يتعاملوا مع هذا التمر
تسللوا الى البيوت للاسف الشديد في
المنازل لمنازل الضباط وبعد هذه المنازل
هي منازل كانت المجاوره
لضباط نوم
دخلوا هذه المنازل
واحتجزوا الاسر
والتعاملوا تعامل وحظا وسيئا مع النساء
والاطفال ودمروا هذه البيوت ونهبوا في
سابقه اصلا لم يصدق لها مثيل في هذا البلد
او في اي مكان اعلمه في هذا العالم